So Lilly, you're here to tell me a story?
莉莉，你是来给我讲故事的吗？
Yes.
是的。
And I should say, you are Lilly Sullivan. You're one of the producers of our show.
我应该介绍一下，你是莉莉·沙利文，是我们节目的制作人之一。
Mm-hm, I am.
嗯，是的。
So what's the story?
那么，是什么故事？
OK, so this is a story that I heard growing up. It was one of those things I was told as like, a scary story when you're a kid. Like an urban legend. And then I've been thinking about it a lot recently, because I read a book recently that I really loved. It's called Her Body and Other Parties, by this writer, Carmen Maria Machado.
好的，这是一个我从小听到大的故事。在我小时候，它被当成那种恐怖故事来讲，就像都市传说一样。最近我经常想起它，因为我最近读了一本我很喜欢的书，书名叫《她的身体和其他派对》，作者是卡门·玛丽亚·马查多。
It's a finalist for the National Book Award, and she retells the story in one of the short stories in her book. And it just stuck in my head. And it's just something that I've been thinking about a lot recently.
这本书入围了国家图书奖，她在书中的一篇短篇小说里重述了这个故事。它一直在我脑海里挥之不去，也是我最近经常思考的事情。
And so what happens? How does it go?
那么发生了什么？故事是怎么发展的？
OK, so a girl and her mom are on vacation in Paris. And they're just traveling, and they've been there for a few days. And the mom, she gets sick. And so the girl gets a doctor.
好的，有个女孩和她妈妈在巴黎度假。她们在旅行，已经待了几天了。然后妈妈生病了，女孩就去找了医生。
And the doctor comes to the hotel. He spends a while examining her, and he's like, she's really sick. We need to deal with this immediately. And he tells the daughter, you need to go across the city. I have medicine. It can save her. You have to go get it while I tend to her, sends her downstairs.
医生来到酒店，检查了一会儿，说：“她病得很重，我们必须马上处理。”他对女儿说：“你需要穿过城市去拿药，这药能救她。趁我照顾她的时候，你快去拿。”就把她打发下楼了。
And the guy at the front desk, the hotel manager, takes her out, and he puts her in a cab. And he goes to the taxi driver and, in French, tells him directions to where she's supposed to go. And it's on the other side of the city. So the girl is in the back of the cab.
前台的工作人员，也就是酒店经理，带她出去并让她上了出租车。他用法语告诉司机要去的地方，目的地在城市的另一头。女孩就这样坐在出租车后座。
And it's just taking forever. The taxi driver is making all these loops and getting lost. . And she's kind of frantic in the back, needing to get back. But she finally gets there. She gets the pills. She jumps back in the cab. And they drive back to the hotel.
路上花了很长时间。出租车司机绕来绕去，好像迷路了。她在后座很焦急，急着要回去。但她最终还是到了，拿到了药，又跳上出租车，赶回酒店。
She runs into the building. And she's running past the hotel manager. And he stops her. And he says, miss, can I help you? And she says, yeah, I have it. I found the medicine. I'm just going back up. He's like, I'm sorry. I've never seen you before.
她冲进大楼，跑过酒店经理时被他拦住了。他问：“小姐，有什么可以帮您吗？”她说：“有的，我有药了，我找到了，我要回楼上去。”他说：“抱歉，我以前没见过您。”
And she's like, no, you just put me in a cab. I'm staying here with my mother. She's upstairs. And she's sick, and the doctor is with her. And he's like, we don't have any guests staying here right now.
她说：“不，你刚把我送上出租车，我跟我母亲住在这里。她就在楼上，她病了，医生正在照顾她。”他说：“我们现在没有住店的客人。”
And so she runs past him. She runs upstairs. She goes to the room. And she opens the door. And the room where her mother was, it's empty. The furniture is all different. The walls are a different color. Everything is rearranged.
她从他身边跑过去，冲上楼，打开房门。她母亲住的房间现在空空如也，家具全变了，墙壁颜色也不同了，一切都重新布置过了。
And the hotel manager kind of chases her up. And he's like, seriously, miss, you need to leave. You can't just be in here. And so she's really confused. She starts running down the halls looking for them.
酒店经理追了上来，说：“说真的，小姐，您得离开。您不能待在这儿。”她非常困惑，开始跑遍走廊去寻找她们。
Them being the doctor and her mom.
她们指的就是那个医生和她妈妈。
Yeah, and so she runs out of the hotel. She runs into the street. And she just starts asking everybody. You know, I'm looking for my mom. Have you seen her?
是的，她跑出酒店，跑上街头，开始询问每个人：“我在找我妈妈，你们见过她吗？”
So what happens to her?
那她最后怎么样了？
Well, she just keeps looking. Years pass.
嗯，她一直找下去，岁月流逝。
Oh, it's a fable.
哦，这是一个寓言故事。
Right. Right.
对。对。
This isn't a real story.
这不是一个真实的故事。
Right. And, you know, she's young. She's in Paris. She doesn't know anybody. And she just keeps wandering and looking. And in the eyes of everyone in Paris, she kind of becomes this madwoman wandering the streets of Paris saying, "where is my mother, where is my mother."
对。而且，你知道，她很年轻，身在巴黎，谁也不认识。她就这样一直徘徊寻找。在巴黎人眼里，她成了一个在街头游荡的疯女人，嘴里念叨着：“我妈妈在哪里，我妈妈在哪里。”
And sometimes, she wonders it, too. Did I invent all of this in my head? She wonders if it happened at all. But at the same time, she knows that it happened. Like, she was staying there with her mother.
有时，她自己也在想：这一切是我头脑中编造出来的吗？她怀疑这一切是否真的发生过。但同时，她又确信它发生过。毕竟，她确实曾和母亲住在那儿。
Lilly, you said that this story has been stuck in your head for a while. And I know it has because I know that it was your impetus for putting together today's show. And you've been thinking about it for months, actually. Talk about why.
莉莉，你说这个故事在你脑海里盘踞很久了。我知道它确实如此，因为我知道这就是你策划今天节目的动力。事实上，你已经想了几个月了。说说为什么吧。
She goes through something in that story that I feel like I've gone through, I think that a lot of women go through all the time. And it can happen in these really small ways. They don't get talked about because they're so small. So here's an example. So years ago when I was just first getting into radio, you know, I had just graduated from this radio program. I got this little scholarship thing to go to this conference with a lot of people who have been in radio forever.
她在故事中经历的事情，我觉得我经历过，而且我觉得很多女性一直在经历。这可能以非常微小的方式发生，因为太琐碎而无人谈论。我举个例子：几年前，我刚入行做广播时，刚从一个广播课程毕业。我拿了一个小奖学金去参加一个会议，那里有很多资深的广播前辈。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was also, you know, one of those scholarships where we're all people of color. We're all young, in a new career. And it was all people who are older. And you know, public radio is mostly--
那也是那种针对少数族裔的奖学金项目，我们都很年轻，事业刚起步。而其他人年纪都很大。你知道，公共广播界主要是……
White.
白人。
Yeah. Yeah. So you're there and you're like, the young person of color who doesn't know anything about radio.
对。对。所以你站在那里，就像是一个对广播一无所知的年轻少数族裔。
Right, yeah.
没错，是的。
It was a little awkward or uncomfortable. And there was this older person who was a pretty big deal in radio. And he was doing this thing where he would kind of come up and talk to me like a normal person and, you know, say professional things about radio. And then he would-- you know, it's a conference. So you see people, and you walk away, and you mingle.
当时有点尴尬或不自在。有个年纪较大的广播界大人物，他走过来和我谈话，表现得像个正常人，说些专业的广播事宜。然后他……你知道，那是会议，你会看到不同的人，走开，去社交。
And then he would kind of walk away. And then he would be on the other side of the room, and he would just kind of like, leer at me from a distance, kind of all the time. It felt like constantly, and he would just-- you know, he'd be waggling his eyebrows, pursing his lips. You know, like, squinting eyes.
然后他会走开。之后他在房间另一头，一直盯着我看。感觉好像是持续不断的，他会……你知道，挑动眉毛，撅起嘴唇。你知道，比如眯起眼睛。
So corny.
太俗气了。
I know. So every time I would turn, he would, you know, catch my eye and like raise his eyebrows again like, still here. He was messing with me. I mean, but it was weird, because then, a few minutes later, he would just walk up to me, and then start acting totally normal, as if he hadn't been doing that.
我知道。所以每次我转头，他就会捕捉到我的目光，再次挑眉，好像在说“我还在这儿”。他在逗我。但这很奇怪，因为几分钟后，他会走过来，表现得完全正常，就好像他刚才什么都没做一样。
Oh, wow.
哦，天哪。
He would just, oh, you're here with this program. It's a really interesting program. And it's important to cultivate new people of color in radio. And then as part of the conference, there was an event one night. And, you know, there was alcohol and, people were drinking.
他会说：“噢，你是跟着这个项目来的。这个项目很有趣，培养广播界新的少数族裔人才很重要。”会议期间有一天晚上有个活动。你知道，有酒水，人们在喝酒。
And he was standing with a group of men. They're looking at me, and they're whispering. It felt like they were talking about me. I mean, they were. I could tell that they were talking about me. Someone would look at me, saying something, and then someone would laugh.
他当时和一群男人站在一起。他们看着我，窃窃私语。感觉他们在谈论我。我是说，他们确实在谈论。有人会看我一眼，说些什么，然后有人大笑。
Did you have a feeling about what they were probably saying?
你有没有感觉到他们可能在说什么？
I mean, I think they were just talking about like, me as a woman, how I look. Things like that. And I think that he was telling them that he was going to sleep with me, or something like that. That's the way they were looking at me. They were like, whispering to each other and squinting their eyes. And they were laughing at me.
我想他们可能是在谈论我作为女性的样子之类的。我觉得他在告诉他们他要跟我睡觉，或者类似的话。他们看我的眼神就是那样。他们凑在一起低语，眯着眼睛，对我嘲笑。
And then, he comes up to me and just acts totally normal, and tells me that I should come over and come meet them. You know, he'd be happy to make some introductions. They're good people to know in radio. And so I go over with him. And I like, put out my hand to meet them. And no one shook my hand. And they all just kind of laughed and looked at each other. And I just--
然后，他走过来表现得完全正常，告诉我应该过去见见他们。你知道，他很高兴为我介绍，他们是广播界值得结识的人。于是我跟他过去，我伸出手想和他们打招呼。没有人握我的手。他们只是互相看看，笑了笑，而我……
Whoa.
哇。
Yeah, it wasn't great. It was really embarrassing. But it was so subtle. It just felt humiliating in a way that I knew would sound silly if I tried to tell someone. And then later, I talked to people about it. And they were a little skeptical. You know, they were like, those people, they wouldn't have done that, the people who make the decisions in radio. But I was like, I just, I know that it happened.
是的，感觉并不好，非常尴尬。但这一切太微妙了。那种屈辱感，我知道如果我试着告诉别人，听起来会很傻。后来，我和别人提起过，他们有点怀疑。他们说：“那些人，广播界做决策的人，不会做那种事。”但我心里清楚，我知道那确实发生了。
And then in your mind, you're basically doing what the woman is doing in the story, which is like, this is definitely true. But wait, is this true?
所以你当时脑子里基本上在做那个故事里的女人做的事，就是“这绝对是真的，但等等，这真的是真的吗？”
Kind of. Because, yeah, I mean, a little bit. Because, like, on the one hand, you know what it's like when people are kind of laughing at you when you put out your hand, and no one shakes it.
某种程度上。因为，是的，我稍微有一点这种感觉。因为一方面，你知道当人们在你伸出手时嘲笑你，且没人握手的感觉。
Yeah, that seems pretty blatant. That seems like hard to make a mistake about.
是的，那看起来相当明目张胆，很难产生误解。
It does seem blatant, right?
确实看起来很明目张胆，对吧？
Right.
对。
But then when people say, you must have misread everything. And the guy himself is acting like everything is totally fine. You're kind of like, is it possible that I misread everything? Am I overreacting? Did I just read all of that wrong?
但当人们说“你肯定误读了一切”，而那个人又表现得一切正常时，你就会想：有没有可能是我误读了？是我反应过度了吗？我是不是理解错了？
OK, so the show that you have put together today, Lilly, was kind of inspired by that Paris story, right?
好的，莉莉，你今天策划的节目，某种程度上就是受那个巴黎故事的启发，对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
And then we just explained to the audience that it has two stories about women. And in each of the stories, something kind of weird and unsettling happens to these women. And the world does not acknowledge how weird and wrong these things are. But in addition, unlike the woman in the Paris story and unlike you at the conference, the women in these stories, they don't think anything has gone wrong.
我们刚刚向听众解释了，节目里有两个关于女性的故事。在每一个故事中，她们都遭遇了一些奇怪且令人不安的事情。而这个世界并不承认这些事情有多奇怪、多错误。但此外，与巴黎故事里的女人和你当时的情况不同，这些故事里的女性一开始并不觉得有什么不对劲。
Not at first. At first, they think everything is fine because everyone around them acts like everything is fine. And only later do they start to realize, wait, something bad did happen.
不是一开始就觉得。起初，她们认为一切都很好，因为周围的人都表现得一切正常。直到后来，她们才开始意识到：“等等，确实发生了糟糕的事情。”
And so that is going to be our show today, two stories that, I have to say, are eye-opening. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
这就是我们今天的节目，两个我必须说非常发人深省的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《此美国生活》。请继续收听。
Act 1-- "The Old Man on My Shoulder." This first story, when the producers were working on it, started doing interviews for the story, it seemed like every single interview they came back so surprised at what they were learning. They really set out having no idea what they would find. A warning-- this story has sexual content. It's probably not right for children. And it begins with something that happened to our producer, Elna Baker.
第一幕——“肩上的老头”。这个故事在制作人采访时，他们每次回来都对所听到的感到惊讶。他们出发时根本不知道会发现什么。警告——这个故事包含性内容，可能不适合儿童收听。故事从我们的制作人艾尔娜·贝克身上发生的事情开始。
A few months ago I was talking to a guy I know, Rory, when Mormonism came up. "You grew up Mormon? You have to meet my fiancee, Reagan," he told me. "She was Mormon, too. You guys will have so much in common." I know that's like saying, you're black, meet my other black friend. But in this case, he was right.
几个月前，我在和一位我认识的朋友罗里聊天，聊到了摩门教。“你是摩门教长大的？那你一定要见见我的未婚妻里根，”他告诉我。“她也是摩门教的，你们会很有共同语言。”我知道这听起来就像是在说“你是黑人，去见见我的另一个黑人朋友”。但在这种情况下，他是对的。
Within an hour of meeting Reagan, we were singing church songs together, like (SINGING) When I grow up, I want to be a mother and have a family. One little, two little, three little babies of my own. Of all the jobs for me, I'll choose no other. I'll have a family. Four little, five little, six little babies in my home.
见到里根不到一小时，我们就开始一起唱教会歌曲，比如（唱）：“当我长大，我想成为母亲并拥有一个家庭。一个、两个、三个我自己的宝宝。在所有工作中，我别无他选。我会拥有一个家庭。四个、五个、六个宝宝在我的家中。”
All this while Rory looked on in horror. Reagan says that Rory is constantly bowled over by the things she tells him.
罗里在一旁惊恐地看着。里根说罗里经常被她告诉他的事情吓得目瞪口呆。
You know, it started out kind of fun and cute. And I'd be like, you know when you're singing around a piano with your family? And he's like, no, nobody does that. That's not a normal thing for people's childhoods. So it started out kind of cute like that. And then one day, I'm like, you know when you're in an office with an old man, and the doors shut, and you're talking about sex things?
你知道，一开始这听起来还有点有趣和可爱。我会说：“你知道那种和家人在钢琴旁唱歌的感觉吗？”他会说：“不，没人会那样。这不是人们童年的常态。”所以起初是可爱的。但后来有一天，我说：“你知道那种和老男人待在办公室里，门关着，谈论性话题的感觉吗？”
Reagan's referring to the Mormon practice of confessing your sexual sins to the bishop. This usually starts when you're 12, for boys and girls. Reagan told Rory about a time she was confessing, and the bishop rose from his desk and put his hand on her knee. Even as an adult in her 30s telling the story, she didn't totally understand how shocking this was, but Rory did.
里根指的是摩门教向主教忏悔性罪的习俗。这通常从12岁开始，无论男女。里根告诉罗里她忏悔时的一次经历，主教从办公桌后站起来，把手放在她膝盖上。即使作为30多岁的大人讲述这个故事时，她也不完全理解这有多么令人震惊，但罗里理解。
And what was his response?
他有什么反应？
Well, he repeated the whole thing, like, you mean to tell me that you were in an office alone with a man with the door shut, and he was asking sexual questions, and then he came out from behind his desk and put his hand on your knee? That kind of thing. And then, and your parents allowed that? Your parents weren't mad about that?
他重复了整个过程，比如：“你是说你被单独关在办公室里，和个男人在一起，门关着，他在问性问题，然后他从桌子后出来，把手放在你膝盖上？”类似这种。然后说：“你父母竟然允许这样？你父母不生气吗？”
How did that make you feel?
这让你感觉如何？
Well, it made me feel everything all over again. It really made me feel the shame and humiliation that I felt when I was 12. 12 to 18.
这让我重新感受到了所有的一切。它真的让我再次体会到我12岁到18岁时感到的羞耻和屈辱。
It was nice to talk to someone else about this. From the ages of 12 to 27, I was supposed to walk into my bishop's office and confess anytime I did anything sexual. But unlike old-fashioned Catholic confession, there was no curtain or anonymity. And Mormon bishops, they're not paid or trained clergy. They don't wear robes.
能和别人谈论这件事真好。从12岁到27岁，我被要求走进主教的办公室，忏悔我所做的任何性相关的事情。但与传统的古老天主教忏悔不同，那里没有帘子，也没有匿名性。摩门教主教不是领薪水的、受过训练的神职人员。他们不穿长袍。
They are men who are chosen by the church to volunteer their time and serve as basically pastors for a two-to-five-year period. They keep their regular jobs. One of my bishops, a good one, was a food scientist who helped invent Pop Rocks. Another was an investment banker named Chad.
他们是被教会选中的人，自愿贡献时间，在两到五年内担任牧师。他们还有正式工作。我的一位主教，是个好人，是发明“跳跳糖”的食品科学家。另一位叫查德，是个投资银行家。
I'd sit across from Chad in a little office at church and admit to a sexual encounter. And Chad would ask follow-up questions. "Did you go to first base or second? He put his hands where? Was it under the bra, or over the bra? Did you like it?"
我会坐在教堂里一个小办公室里，在查德对面承认一次性经历。查德会问一些后续问题。“你进展到一垒还是二垒？他把手放在哪儿了？是在胸罩里面还是外面？你喜欢吗？”
To be forgiven of sexual sin, I was required to tell the bishop. So while I often felt ashamed or humiliated in the room, I never questioned the process itself. It was routine, like going to the dentist. You turned yourself in whenever there was anything to report. And on top of that, once or twice a year, you were required to go to this thing called a worthiness interview.
为了获得性罪的宽恕，我必须告诉主教。所以虽然我常常感到羞耻或屈辱，但我从未质疑过这个过程本身。这就像看牙医一样是例行公事，只要有情况就要去汇报。更何况，每年还要一两次被要求参加所谓的“配称面谈”。
Everyone did this, no exception, from the ages of 12 to 18. These were like checkups for your spirituality. The bishop would ask you a series of questions like, do you believe in God? Are you a full tithe payer? Are you honest in your dealings with your fellow man? In the midst of these questions about your faith, he'd ask if you obey the law of chastity. Reagan's first worthiness interview was pretty confusing.
每个人都要参加，没有例外，从12岁到18岁。这就像是灵魂的体检。主教问你一系列问题，比如：你相信上帝吗？你全额缴纳什一税吗？你对待邻人诚实吗？在这些关于信仰的问题中，他会问你是否遵守贞洁律。里根的第一次配称面谈非常令人困惑。
They sort of graze over everything until you get to chastity. And he said, "are you obeying the law of chastity?" And I didn't know what that word meant. And so I asked him to explain it more, and he said, "are you engaging in sexual things like petting and necking?"
他们会草草带过一切，直到提到贞洁。他说：“你在遵守贞洁律吗？”我不知道这个词的意思，于是请他进一步解释。他说：“你在进行性行为，比如调情和爱抚吗？”
And I also didn't know what petting and necking was. I mean, I was about as innocent as a 12-year-old can be. I was home-schooled, and everything. So I wasn't even around language like-- you know, any kind of sexual or lewd language of any kind.
我也不知道“调情和爱抚”是什么。我是说，我作为一个12岁的孩子天真极了，我是家庭教育长大的，所以甚至没接触过那种语言……任何性或淫秽的语言。
Especially not language from the 1950s.
更别提那是1950年代的词汇了。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, so I didn't know what necking or petting was. And so I think I said, like, I don't think so. And I remember the feeling of my heart beating in my ears. You know, I felt my whole body was so hot.
对，没错。所以我不明白什么是“调情和爱抚”。我想我回答说：“我想没有吧。”我记得那种心跳在耳边回响的感觉。你知道，我觉得全身都在发烫。
And even though I didn't know what it was, and I didn't think I had done it, I felt like I had done it. You know, I felt like I was really guilty. And it seemed like every question up until that point was really not important, and then this was the big question. This was like, the whole-- you know, climax of the interview.
即便我不知道那是什么，也不认为自己做过，但我感觉自己好像做了。我觉得我很有罪。似乎在那之前的所有问题都不重要，而这才是终极问题，是整个谈话的“高潮”。
And then I also became bad after that. I became completely obsessed with necking, and petting, and finding out what it meant. Anytime anything would happen in a movie, anything sexual at all, I'd be like, I think that's petting. The interviews kick-started something with me.
从那之后我就变坏了。我开始沉迷于“调情和爱抚”，急于弄懂那意味着什么。电影里出现任何性相关的情节，我就会想：我想那是爱抚吧。那些面谈在我心中激发了一些东西。
I made my Barbies do everything that you can possibly imagine. It was like a bloodbath. My Barbies went from just playing house to like, doing angel dust, and having like, orgies within a matter of weeks.
我让我的芭比娃娃做了你能想象到的所有事。简直是一场血腥屠杀。我的芭比娃娃在几周内从过家家变成了嗑药和群交。
When Reagan was 16, she said she finally got a boyfriend to experiment with. And she did neck and pet with him. But whatever fun she had was gone the second it was over.
里根16岁时，终于交了个男朋友做实验。她确实和对方调情和爱抚了。但不管过程有多快乐，结束的那一刻快感就消失了。
Did you immediately, like right after, think like, oh no, now I have to tell the bishop.
你是不是立刻，在那之后马上就想：“噢不，现在我得告诉主教了。”
Yes. Yes, instantly. I went home, and I remember feeling really excited that I had necked and petted. And then the next day, I was just guilt ridden. The whole day I was like-- it was like I had a hangover, or something. Like a-- I don't know. I was laying in bed, like thinking about it, and worrying about it all day. And I didn't tell him, or talk about it until I was asked to go in for an interview.
是的。是的，瞬间。我回家了，记得当时因为调情和爱抚感到非常兴奋。但第二天，我被负罪感包围了。整天我都在……就像宿醉一样，或者什么的。我躺在床上，整天都在思考和担忧。我一直没敢告诉他，直到我被要求去参加面谈。
And the door was shut. I was sitting there. I was 16. And he asked me all the questions. And then he asked me if I was keeping the law of chastity. And I said no. I said no. And he came out from behind his desk, and pulled up a chair close to me, and put his hand on my knee.
门关着。我坐在那儿，16岁。他问完所有问题后，问我是否遵守贞洁律。我说没有。我说没有。他从桌子后出来，把椅子拉近我，把手放在我膝盖上。
This is the story she told her fiancee, Rory.
这就是她告诉她未婚夫罗里的故事。
And then said, "did you do this more than once?" And I said no, I only did it once. And then he said, "did you have intercourse?" And I said no. And then he said, "did you like it?" And I said no. "Have you thought about doing it again?"
然后他说：“你做过不止一次吗？”我说没有，只有一次。他说：“你有过性交吗？”我说没有。然后他说：“你喜欢吗？”我说没有。“你有想过再做一次吗？”
And did he define what it was?
他有定义那是什么吗？
Well, it was all kind of vague things. Like, you know, intercourse was probably the most specific. But I remember him asking me things like, "did you impersonate sex?" Which I didn't totally understand.
嗯，一切都很模糊。比如，你知道，性交可能是最具体的。但我记得他问我一些像“你有模仿性行为吗？”之类的问题，我并不完全理解。
That's a really weird way to put it, too.
那也是一种非常奇怪的表达方式。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的，是的。
Hey, it's me, sex.
嘿，是我，性。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Yeah.
是的。
For penance you put together a plan that requires frequent check-ins, and you do assignments, like reading church literature about not having sex. For a while you can't take the sacrament, our version of communion. This can feel like public shaming, like everyone notices. It's incredibly embarrassing because if you're a young woman, the assumption is it's sex related. Reagan's bishop set up more meetings with her.
作为惩罚，他制定了一个计划，要求经常汇报，还要完成任务，比如阅读关于禁止性行为的教会资料。一段时间内你不能领圣餐——也就是我们的圣餐仪式。这可能会感觉像公开羞辱，好像每个人都注意到了。这令人极其尴尬，因为如果你是个年轻女性，人们默认这一定与性有关。里根的主教为她安排了更多会面。
And then he called my house about twice a month, to check on me. I felt really humiliated. I felt-- I felt like, evil, almost, you know? I felt like everything-- I felt like I was just such a disappointment, and I made my family look bad, and all of that.
然后他每个月给我家打两次电话，检查我的情况。我感到非常屈辱。我觉得……我觉得自己几乎是邪恶的，你知道吗？我感觉一切……我感觉自己是个巨大的失望，让我的家庭蒙羞，诸如此类。
One morning last December, I opened up Facebook and saw this petition going around by a Mormon named Sam Young. He used to be a bishop, and he was calling on the church to stop these sexually explicit interviews. This was the first time I'd ever heard them referred to as sexually explicit.
去年12月的一天早上，我打开脸书，看到一份由一位名叫萨姆·扬的摩门教徒发起的请愿书。他曾是主教，呼吁教会停止这些露骨的性面谈。这是我第一次听到这些被定义为“性露骨”。
He posted a list of 29 questions different church members said that they'd been asked in their interviews with their bishops. As I read down the list, I realized that I had been asked 13 of them. Questions like, do you masturbate? Where and how did your boyfriend touch you? Where were his fingers? Were your nipples hard? Were you wet?
他发布了一份名单，记录了教会成员在面谈中被问到的29个问题。读完列表，我意识到我被问过其中的13个。比如：你手淫吗？你的男朋友在哪里以及如何触摸你的？他的手指在哪里？你的乳头变硬了吗？你湿了吗？
It took seeing them all together for me to realize how bad it actually was. There were stories of abuse on Sam's website. Some are extreme, like bishops who convinced children that if they masturbated with them, the desire to do it would go away. I was never physically abused, just asked questions.
直到看到它们汇总在一起，我才意识到这有多糟糕。萨姆的网站上有很多虐待案例。有些很极端，比如有主教说服孩子如果和他们一起手淫，欲望就会消失。我没受到身体虐待，只是被问了这些问题。
As a bishop, Sam said he never asked these questions, and he was never asked them as a kid. He found out about them from a friend whose son was asked about masturbation. Sam couldn't believe it. He posted about it on Facebook, and the stories came flooding in.
作为主教，萨姆说他从未问过这些问题，他小时候也没被问过。他从一个朋友那里得知这些，那位朋友的儿子被问到了手淫的问题。萨姆简直不敢相信。他在脸书上发布了这件事，相关故事如潮水般涌来。
Of his six daughters, four told him that they'd been asked if they masturbated. One of his youngest said she didn't know what the word meant. She was 12. So she looked it up on the internet, and this introduced her to porn. Sam thought if he brought all this to the attention of the church, they'd stop these explicit questions.
他有六个女儿，其中四个告诉他她们曾被问及是否手淫。其中最小的一个说她不知道那个词的意思，当时她才12岁。于是她在网上查了，结果接触到了色情。萨姆认为，如果他让教会注意到这一切，他们就会停止这些露骨的提问。
The church response was that bishops are not supposed to be, quote, "unnecessarily probing or invasive in their questions." But what's necessary and unnecessary is left up to each individual bishop to decide. The church doesn't define exactly where the line is. As the story got more heat, the church issued new guidelines this spring, saying kids could have a parent or an adult in the room when meeting with the bishop.
教会的回应是，主教不应该“过度盘问或侵入性地提问”。但什么叫必要，什么是不必要，完全由各主教个人决定。教会没有明确界定界限在哪里。随着舆论发酵，教会今年春天发布了新指南，称孩子们在面谈时可以有父母或成年人在场。
The church claims this had nothing to do with Sam's petition, but clearly he had touched a nerve. He was excommunicated from the church in September for acting, quote "in clear, open, and deliberate public opposition to the church." And a lot of Mormons online resisted his claims.
教会声称这与萨姆的请愿无关，但显然他触动了神经。他因“公开、明确、蓄意地反对教会”在九月被驱逐出教。许多网络上的摩门教徒抵制他的说法。
They defended their bishops, saying they hadn't been asked inappropriate or disturbing questions. That these incidents were isolated and unusual, or that Sam was making these stories up. That they hadn't happened at all. But I knew they'd happened, because they'd happened to me. And they stuck with me. I had rarely talked about it with any friends, and never my family.
他们为自己的主教辩护，说他们没被问过不恰当或令人不安的问题。说这些事件是孤立且反常的，或者萨姆在编造故事。说这些事情根本没发生过。但我知道它们发生了，因为发生在我身上。它们一直萦绕在我心头。我很少跟朋友谈论这件事，更从未告诉过家人。
Even all these years later, I feel like it's my fault. That I somehow deserved these humiliating encounters. And talking to Reagan and reading the stories on Sam's website, I wondered, how widespread is this? It just so happens that we have another person on staff who grew up Mormon. So together, we just started calling people, some we knew, some we didn't, some were practicing Mormons, others had left the church. And people definitely remembered their bishop interviews.
即使过了这么多年，我仍觉得是我的错。觉得我以某种方式应得这些羞辱的待遇。和里根交谈并阅读萨姆网站上的故事后，我开始想：这有多普遍？恰好我们的一位工作人员也是摩门教长大的。于是我们开始给人们打电话，有些认识，有些不认识，有些是虔诚的摩门教徒，有些已经离开了教会。人们确实记得他们的面谈。
They'd be like, well, how long did it last? Or did he put his fingers in you, or did you put your fingers on him?
他们会问：“那持续了多久？或者他把手指伸进你身体了吗，还是你把手指放在他身上了？”
And I think he asked me if I had made her orgasm. I remember going really red in the face, an extreme amount of anxiety. I felt like my throat was closing.
我想他问我是否让她达到高潮了。我记得脸涨得通红，极度焦虑。感觉喉咙被堵住了。
And I was only 11, and I'd never had a boyfriend. I told him, yes, I'm keeping the law of chastity. He said, "are you lying to me?" I said no. And he said, "are you sure you're not lying to me?" And I thought, does the bishop know something about me that I don't know?
我当时只有11岁，从未交过男朋友。我告诉他：“是的，我遵守贞洁律。”他说：“你在对我撒谎吗？”我说没有。他说：“你确定没撒谎吗？”我当时想：主教是不是知道一些我不知道的关于我自己的事？
We reached 10 people. And to our surprise, all 10 said that they had had at least one experience with a bishop where they felt the line of questioning went too far, or became overly explicit. These interactions left them feeling deeply uncomfortable and ashamed, to the point that most of them had never shared their stories with anyone. This led me to ask my siblings, and of the five of us, four had had bad experiences.
我们联系了10个人，出乎意料的是，这10个人都表示，他们至少有一次与主教的经历中，感觉提问越界了，或者变得过于露骨。这些互动让他们感到深深的不安和羞耻，以至于大多数人从未与任何人分享过他们的故事。这促使我问了我的兄弟姐妹，我们五个人中，有四个有过糟糕的经历。
I don't want to say every Mormon feels this way about their bishops. The therapist I contacted, who specializes in sex and relationships, and works with current and former church members, estimated that bishop interviews only come up with one out of eight of her clients. And talking about chastity is just a small part of what bishops do. Lots of people have positive experiences with their bishops, including me, and the people we talked to.
我不想说每个摩门教徒都对主教有这种感觉。我联系的那位专门研究性与关系的治疗师，她的客户包括现任和前任教会成员，她估计只有八分之一的客户提到过面谈问题。谈论贞洁只是主教工作的一小部分。很多人和主教有过积极的经历，包括我自己，以及我们采访过的人。
Yes, some bishops went too far, but we had others who didn't. You get a new one every few years. But bishop interviews can be hugely consequential for your life. To attend any Mormon-run college, you need your bishop to give you what's called an ecclesiastical endorsement, which is basically a letter stating that you're a faithful Mormon obeying the church's teachings.
是的，有些主教确实越界了，但也有没越界的。你每几年就会换一个。但面谈可能对你的一生影响巨大。要进入任何摩门教办的大学，都需要主教提供所谓的“教会推荐书”，这基本上就是一封信，证明你是遵守教义的虔诚成员。
I talked to a woman named Alisha. She's from Utah in her early 40s. When she was 20, she went to get her ecclesiastical endorsement to go to BYU, Brigham Young University. Alisha had previously had sex with her boyfriend, but says she stopped, and had been abstinent for a while. She hadn't confessed it yet, though.
我采访了一位叫阿莉莎的女性，她来自犹他州，40出头。20岁时，她去申请进入杨百翰大学的推荐信。阿莉莎之前和男友有过性行为，但她说她已经停止了，有一段时间一直禁欲。不过她还没去忏悔。
And her feeling was that if she was going to a church school, she wanted to do it the right way. She wanted to be on the up and up. She figured the interview would go OK if she just told the truth because she'd only had positive experiences with bishops before. And so she made an appointment with her bishop.
她的想法是，既然要去教会学校，她想用正确的方式去做。她想坦诚相待。她以为只要实话实说，面谈就会顺利，因为她之前和主教的接触都是积极的。于是她预约了面谈。
He asked me about masturbation, which I had never been asked before. So that was a little bit surprising. And I said yes. But then he proceeded to ask me, "did you use your hands, or did you use a device?" And immediately, like every cell in my body was on alert.
他问了我关于手淫的问题，我以前从未被问过。这有点令我惊讶。我回答了是。但他接着问我：“你用手还是用工具？”瞬间，我身体的每一个细胞都警觉起来。
Like when you're walking down an alley, and all of a sudden you feel extremely uncomfortable. That's how I felt. Like, right out of the get go. So I said, well, why does it matter? And he said, "well, I just want to get a sense so I can advise you on triggers, and what to avoid."
就像你走在小巷里，突然感到极其不安。就是那种感觉。从一开始就是这样。于是我说：“这重要吗？”他说：“我只是想了解一下，好给你建议，告诉你什么是诱因，应该避免什么。”
He asked her a bunch of other sexual questions. She said yes to all of them, and confessed she had sex with her boyfriend.
他问了她一堆其他性问题。她都如实回答，并承认和男友发生了性关系。
He proceeded to ask me, where were you? Were you in your bed, in a car? Did you climax? Did he climax? I said, does it make it less of a sin if I climaxed, or does it make it more of a sin? I was confused. I don't know what the rules are. Like, I didn't know.
他继续问我：“你们在哪儿？是在床上还是车里？你高潮了吗？他高潮了吗？”我说：“如果我高潮了，算更严重的罪吗？如果不高潮，就轻一点吗？”我很困惑。我不知道规则是什么。我是说，我不知道。
Definitely, it was like he sat forward in his chair. And I felt like he was watching porn that was my life, and not his business. That was my take, that he was using my story and his power to create pictures in his head that he could take pleasure from. I mean, that's how it felt.
确实，他当时身体前倾。我觉得他在看一部关于我生活的色情片，而那根本不关他的事。我的看法是，他在利用我的故事和权力在脑海中描绘画面，并从中寻求快感。我是说，感觉就是那样。
At some point he said, "So all you guys do is have sex? You guys don't do anything else?" And I'm thinking, no, this is a boyfriend that we do a lot. Like, he's in a band. We go do all these shows. Like, I help roadie for him. Our relationship is not the sex. It's just what you're asking about. And now you're making it sound like that's the only thing we do. It was bizarre. But I needed that signature.
有一刻他说：“所以你们除了做爱就没别的了？你们什么都不做吗？”我心想，不，我们有很多共同爱好。他有个乐队，我们一起去演出。我帮他搬设备。我们的关系不仅限于性，但这却是你唯一询问的内容。而现在你把它说得好像我们只会做那件事一样。这太离奇了。但我需要那个签名。
And eventually got it, but not without paying a price. She was too scared to report him. She thought it could backfire. And she had to keep meeting with him once a week. She said she always felt sick beforehand, and tried to think of excuses not to go.
最终她拿到了签名，但代价沉重。她太害怕举报他了，担心会有反作用。她不得不每周去见他一次。她说去之前总是感觉恶心，试图找借口不去。
It's hard because it's not like I could have said, this man is molesting me, or raping me, or-- And I've had other experiences that were sexual pressure put on me, you know, with hands, that were less traumatic than this.
很难受，因为我没法说“这个男人在骚扰我，或强奸我”。我有过其他经历，受到过性压迫，比如身体接触，但比这个创伤性要小。
I grew up watching this church video that primed me for the role I was supposed to play in the bishop's office. It's called "Godly Sorrow Leads to Repentance." And our teachers would show it to us when they slacked on preparing a lesson. In the video, a young woman named Kim visits her bishop because she's going to get married, and in order to enter the temple, she needs a signed document. A temple recommend, that says she's worthy. Kim sits across the desk from her bishop and he asks--
我从小看教会视频，这些视频预设了我将来在主教办公室的角色。视频名叫《神圣的忧伤带来悔改》。老师们在准备课程懈怠时就会放给我们看。视频里，年轻女性金去见主教，因为她要结婚了，为了进入圣殿，她需要一份签署的文件，即证明她配称的圣殿推荐书。金坐在主教对面，他问……
Is there anything in your life, Kim, that hasn't been resolved with the proper priesthood authority?
金，你的生活中有什么是没经过适当的圣职权柄解决的吗？
Well, before Matt returned from his mission, I was involved with another boy. We probably spent a little too much time together alone.
嗯，在马特从传教归来前，我和另一个男孩在一起过。我们可能单独待的时间太长了。
The bishop waits for her to say more. When Kim doesn't, he nods his head and gestures.
主教等着她说更多。金没说话时，他点头示意。
Go on.
继续说。
I guess things sort of got out of hand.
我想事情有点失控了。
Kim, I know how hard it is to talk about things like this, but I need to know how serious the problem was if I'm going to help resolve it.
金，我知道谈论这些很难，但如果我要帮你解决问题，我必须知道问题的严重性。
I guess we were getting a little too comfortable together. And that's when the problems started.
我想我们当时靠得太近了。然后问题就出现了。
The screen fades and cuts back to the bishop, implying that time has passed, and Kim has spilled her story.
屏幕淡出切回主教画面，暗示时间过去了，金已经倾诉了故事。
What you've told me, Kim, is very serious.
你告诉我的这些，非常严重。
Yeah, but I'm not involved with that guy anymore. It's not a problem now.
是的，但我已经和那个男孩没往来了。现在不是问题了。
The bishop tells her that this is much more severe than she thinks.
主教告诉她这比她想的要严重得多。
I can't have a temple recommend? But the wedding is coming up. The announcements have been sent out. My dress is paid for.
不能领圣殿推荐书？可是婚礼快到了。请帖发了，婚纱也付钱了。
We saw this film a lot, and the cutaway really made an impression. My classmates and I would be like, what do you think she said? So when my bishop first asked me about masturbating when I was 14, it seemed appropriate for us to have an explicit conversation. We were just living in the cutaway.
这电影我们看很多遍，那段切分画面印象深刻。我和同学们会想：她到底说了什么？所以当我14岁时主教第一次问我手淫的问题，我们就觉得进行这种露骨的谈话是合适的。我们只是活在那个切分画面里。
So I told all. I couldn't lie to the bishop. That would be like lying to God. And I was taught that any sexual act I committed before marriage was the second most serious sin next to murder. It was terrifying. I masturbated once when I was 12. I wasn't even aware of what I was doing. I just knew something unusual happened.
所以我全说了。我不能对主教撒谎，那就像对上帝撒谎。我被教导婚前任何性行为都是仅次于谋杀的第二大罪。这太可怕了。我12岁时手淫过一次。我甚至不知道自己在做什么。只知道发生了一些不寻常的事。
Two years later, I learned the church's position on masturbation, which is that it's almost as bad as sex. And I knew sex was almost as bad as murder. When I connected the dots, I was devastated. Unless I repented, I was told I'd be separated from my family in the afterlife, because no unclean thing is allowed in heaven.
两年后，我了解了教会对自慰的立场，即它几乎和性交一样严重。而我知道性交几乎和谋杀一样严重。当我把这些联系起来时，我崩溃了。如果不悔改，我被告知在来世将与家人分离，因为不洁净的东西不能进入天堂。
So I go tell the bishop. But, of course, I'd masturbate again. And each time, I'd immediately be hit with the thought that I was being so selfish. Why would I choose this feeling over my family? The only way to undo it, to get my family back, was to confess.
于是我去告诉主教。但当然，我还会再犯。每次我立刻就会被一种自私的念头击中：为什么我选择这种感觉而不是我的家人？唯一的补救方法，找回家人的方法，就是忏悔。
My dad was a bishop for five years. When I told him recently about the questions my siblings and I were asked, it upset him. He told me he'd never asked anyone those questions, and didn't remember being asked them as a kid. So when exactly did bishops start asking these detailed and embarrassing questions?
我爸爸做过五年主教。当我最近告诉他我兄弟姐妹和我被问到的那些问题时，他很不安。他告诉我他从没问过任何人那些问题，也不记得小时候被问过。那么，主教究竟是从什么时候开始问这些详细且尴尬的问题的？
I talked to three different historians, all Mormon, but independent of the church. And they said the answer was simple. The shift started happening in the '70s. It was the church's reaction to the sexual revolution. They were worried about promiscuity. Someone at MormonLeaks, our version of WikiLeaks, put me in touch with a historian who has a collection of old church manuals that are written specifically for bishops.
我采访了三位历史学家，都是摩门教徒，但独立于教会。他们说答案很简单，这种转变从70年代开始。这是教会对性革命的反应。他们担心滥交。我们的“维基解密”版本——MormonLeaks的某人把我介绍给一位历史学家，他收藏了专门为主教编写的旧教会手册。
Before the 1970s, the manuals told bishops to search for, quote, "immoral or un-Christianlike practices." They don't spell it out with a lot of details. But then in 1975, explicit questions first appear in a bishop's guide which tells bishops to ask prospective missionaries and other young adults whether they've been involved in, quote, "any of the following-- pre or extramarital sexual intercourse, homosexual practices, sexual deviations, petting--" then in parentheses, "the fondling of another's body, and masturbation. Hesitation or uneasiness may suggests that a question needs to be pursued further." End quote.
1970年代以前，手册告诉主教要寻找“不道德或不符合基督教行为的实践”。他们没列出具体细节。但在1975年，明确的问题首次出现在主教指南中，它指示主教询问预备传教士和其他年轻人是否参与了“以下行为：婚前或婚外性交、同性恋行为、性偏差、爱抚”——括号里写着“对他人身体的抚摸”，以及“手淫。犹豫或不安可能暗示问题需要进一步追究。”
When I read this, I was blown away. I felt like, here it is, the blueprint for the system I grew up in. That was 1975. Worthiness interviews with young people officially began in the 1980s. And in the '90s, a pamphlet came out which bishops were told to use in those interviews.
读到这里我惊呆了。我觉得，这就是我成长环境的蓝图。那是1975年。针对年轻人的配称面谈正式开始于1980年代。90年代出了一本手册，主教被要求在面谈时使用。
It was called "For the Strength of Youth." On the cover there was a black and white drawing of a bunch of teenagers, girls with perms and shoulder pads, boys who looked popular. You got one when you turned 12. I loved mine.
手册叫《为了年轻人的力量》。封面上是一群青少年的黑白画，女孩子烫着头、垫着肩，男孩们看起来很受欢迎。12岁时你就会收到一本。我很喜欢我的那本。
Anyway, the pamphlet included a list of forbidden sexual acts like petting, masturbation, and also just thinking too much about sex. The church encouraged bishops to discuss the specific acts listed in the pamphlet during their interviews with young people. And they were free to ask whatever follow-ups they felt they needed to. This is how the system still works today.
总之，手册列出了一些被禁止的性行为，如爱抚、自慰，还有过度思考性。教会鼓励主教在面谈时讨论手册列出的具体行为。他们可以自由询问任何他们觉得需要的后续问题。这就是今天系统运作的方式。
I had a feeling of love for my bishops. I still do. They were seen as the father of our congregation. You felt like you knew them and they knew you. They'd ask about your classes at college or follow up on your daily life. When my father was a bishop, I watched him volunteer his time in between a hectic work schedule and home life to help people find apartments, pay for groceries, be their grief counselor, visit them when they were sick.
我曾对主教充满爱戴之情，现在依然。他们被视为我们会众的父亲。你会觉得你了解他们，他们也了解你。他们会问你的大学课程，跟进你的日常生活。我爸爸做主教时，我看着他在繁忙的工作和家庭生活间隙，志愿贡献时间帮人找公寓、付杂费、做哀伤辅导，在他们生病时探望。
He genuinely loved and helped these people because he cared about them. And my bishops cared about me. I felt relieved when I left the office. Repenting to them lifted the weight of the guilt I'd been carrying. And often, it felt like they were just as uncomfortable asking the questions as I was answering them.
他真心关爱并帮助这些人。我的主教也关怀我。离开办公室时我感到解脱。向他们悔改减轻了我一直背负的负罪感。而且，很多时候，他们问这些问题似乎和我回答时一样尴尬。
But regardless of the intention or behavior of any one bishop, bishop interviews followed me into every sexual encounter. All the women I spoke to had this same problem. For example, I learned that my bishops were more lenient if I wasn't the person initiating. So when I was with guys, I'd strategically make sure they made every move, which meant I was constantly leaning against walls, pressing my boobs out and telepathically communicating, please sir, just touch one boob.
但无论任何主教的意图或行为如何，面谈一直伴随着我的每一场性经历。我采访的所有女性都有同样的问题。例如，我知道如果不是我主动，主教的态度会宽容些。所以和男伴在一起时，我会策略性地确保他们采取所有行动，这意味着我总是靠在墙上，挺出胸部，通过心灵感应沟通：求求你，先生，摸摸那儿。
But even now in my 30s, I have a really hard time with sex. Shocker. I'm no longer Mormon. I haven't been for eight years. And still, when I fool around with someone, there's a voice in my head that keeps track of what I'm doing, like a ref docking points for each progressive move.
即便现在30多岁，我在性方面依然有很大困难。不奇怪。我离开摩门教八年了。但当我和别人亲热时，脑海里总有个声音在记录我做的事，就像个裁判在为每一步进展扣分。
The only way to get this voice to shut up is to leave my body. So I'm there, but not there. The following morning, I wake up to this voice telling me all the things I've done wrong. This leads to panic and anxiety.
让这个声音闭嘴的唯一办法就是离体。我人在那儿，灵魂却不在。第二天醒来，那个声音告诉我所有我做错的事。这导致恐慌和焦虑。
And it's not like I just feel bad for a minute. The feeling lingers for days. Writing this story, I've realized something I never put together until now. I still feel bad for losing my virginity before I got married. I was 28. I wanted to do it the right way.
不仅是那一会儿感觉糟糕，那种感觉会徘徊好几天。写这个故事时，我意识到以前从未想到的一点：我对婚前失去童贞感到羞耻。我那时28岁。我想用正确的方式去做。
I'd made promises to God, and to the people in my life that I'd wait for marriage. I wanted so badly to live up to their expectations. And when I made the choice to have sex, I knew what it meant. I made it knowing I would lose my family for eternity, my community, and my religion. And in spite of all that, I still did it.
我曾向上帝和生命中的人们承诺过我要等到婚后。我太想活出他们的期望了。当我选择发生性关系时，我知道那意味着什么。我在明知会失去永恒的家庭、社区和信仰的情况下仍然那样做了。尽管如此，我还是做了。
And what kind of a person does that make me? This is what I feel every time I have sex. I've wondered how much of this is related to these bishop interviews. And I asked a few people how they thought it impacted them. A couple women said it was easier to have sex if they didn't feel pleasure. The guilt was directly linked to enjoying it. This woman, Courtney, said something I related to a lot.
那我是什么样的人？每次性行为时我都有这种感觉。我好奇这和面谈有多少联系。我问过一些人这如何影响了她们。一些女性说如果感觉不到快感，性行为会更容易些。内疚感直接与享受它联系在一起。这位女性科特妮说了一些我深有共鸣的话。
Having wine before you have sex, or even smoking weed is the only way to get around it-- is if you alter your mind.
性行为前喝酒，甚至抽大麻，是唯一绕过它的方式——如果你改变自己的精神状态的话。
And how much of that directly ties to that interview at 18?
那这在多大程度上直接关联到18岁时的那次面谈？
100%.
100%。
And this is Kate.
这是凯特。
I think constantly having to account to an extraordinarily judgmental outsider about your sex life leaves an external voice. Like, you know how there's like an angel and a devil in cartoons who are always on your shoulder? I think there's always like an old man on our shoulders as Mormon women.
我认为不断要向一个极其挑剔的局外人汇报你的性生活，会留下一个外部的声音。你知道卡通片里总有天使和恶魔在肩上吗？我认为作为摩门教女性，我们的肩膀上总有个老男人。
This has consequences. Dr. Jennifer Finlayson-Fife is the sex therapist I talked to. She's a practicing Mormon and has had hundreds of patients who are current or former members of the church. She said some Mormon women, not all, learned from their bishop interviews to defer to an authority figure when it comes to sex.
这产生了后果。詹妮弗·芬莱森-法伊夫博士是我采访的性治疗师。她是虔诚的摩门教徒，有数百名现任或前任教会成员患者。她说一些摩门教女性学会了在性方面顺从权威人物。
Of course, other parts of the religion reinforce that lesson, too. And these women, during sex, they think about what the man they're with wants or what their bishop would think. They don't think about what they want. This shuts their sexuality down.
当然，宗教的其他部分也强化了这一教训。这些女性在做爱时，想的是男伴想要什么，或者主教会有什么想法。她们不会思考自己想要什么。这关闭了她们的性欲。
I mean some LDS women really see it as a dangerous thing, that sex and desire in and of itself is dangerous to their goodness and dangerous to their identity as a good woman, and to their perception of the ideals of what a good LDS woman does. And so they shut it down in a more fundamental way or don't develop it in a more fundamental way. And then, the task of awakening it in marriage feels almost impossible.
有些LDS女性确实视其为危险的东西，认为性与欲望本身对她们的善良、对她们作为好女性的认同、以及对LDS好女性理想的认知是危险的。所以她们从根本上关闭了它，或者没能从根本上发展它。而结婚后唤醒它感觉几乎是不可能的。
Of course, shutting down means different things. A lot of the women I talked to said that during sex, they leave their bodies, can't even tell what they want. Rebecca was one of the women who told me she enjoys sex. But she still feels held back. She's a practicing Mormon, and she did it the right way. Married a Mormon, waited till marriage to have sex.
当然，关闭意味着不同的东西。我交谈过的许多女性说在做爱时她们会灵魂出窍，甚至不知道自己想要什么。丽贝卡就是其中一位，她说她享受性爱，但仍感到受束缚。她是虔诚的摩门教徒，用正确的方式做了。嫁给了摩门教徒，等到结婚才发生性关系。
I still sometimes will have a feeling of I'm being dirty or slutty if I enjoy this too much, or if I get too into this. Because I feel like somehow, the only pure way to have an orgasm is to be thinking about my husband, who I'm married to for eternity, and our love and worthiness before God. I don't think having those thoughts, for me, is that sexy. I don't want to think about my relationship to God.
如果我太享受它或太投入，有时依然会感到脏或淫荡。因为我觉得仿佛获得高潮的唯一纯洁方式是想着我的丈夫——我和他有永恒的婚约，还有我们在上帝面前的爱与配称。我不想在那种时刻想我和上帝的关系，那对我来说不性感。
What I've started to realize these bishop interviews did to me was I had no space for privacy of any sexual thought. So if I had a sexual thought, God was eavesdropping and heard it. I have to be like, oh, no, turn the thought off. Stop, stop, stop. This is not allowed.
我开始意识到这些面谈对我做了什么：我没有任何性想法的隐私空间。如果我有性想法，上帝在窃听。我不得不说：“不，关闭它。停下，停下，停下。这不被允许。”
Yeah. But I don't blame you for feeling that way, because that's some of our cultural and social programming. I don't think it's intentional. I don't think anybody sat there and thought, let's give these women these huge hang ups they're gonna struggle with the rest of their lives. But it happened.
是的。但我并不怪你有那种感觉，因为那是我们的文化和社会编程。我不认为这是故意的。不认为有人坐在那里想：“让我们给这些女性留下巨大的心结，让她们余生痛苦。”但它发生了。
Right, they didn't plan to give us these hangups. But they did plan to scare the bejesus out of children about sex, in a way that gave us huge hang ups. I wanted to talk to the church about this to understand how it views the bishop interviews today, after the Sam Young controversy. To see if officials really grasp how much their policies had impacted us, and if the church is rethinking these practices.
对，他们没计划给我们留心结。但他们的确计划了要用恐吓手段让孩子对性产生恐惧，这以一种给予我们巨大心理负担的方式。我想和教会谈谈，了解在萨姆·扬争议后，他们今天如何看待面谈。看看官员们是否真的理解他们的政策对我们影响有多深，以及教会是否在反思这些做法。
LDS officials haven't given interviews on this in the past. But the director of Media Relations for the church, Eric Hawkins, agreed to talk. I told him what I'd learned from my interviewees, that these bishop interviews had stayed with us.
LDS官员过去从未就此接受采访。但教会媒体关系主任埃里克·霍金斯同意谈一谈。我告诉他我从受访者那里学到的，这些面谈一直伴随着我们。
I think what you have found is a selection of individuals who have perhaps had that experience, or that feeling, whereas tens of thousands, hundreds of thousands of others have felt very differently about the process, and about-- so as I say, from my perspective, it is always heartbreaking when I hear that someone leaves that conversation not having had that experience.
我认为你找到的是一小部分可能有过那种经历或感觉的人，而成千上万的人对这个过程有着非常不同的感受。所以，正如我所说，从我的角度来看，当听到有人在谈话结束后有那种不好的体验时，总是令人心碎的。
Are these questions supposed to be that explicit?
这些问题本应如此露骨吗？
I think that would depend a little bit on the situation. One of the pieces of counsel that bishops are given is to not be too invasive, to adapt the conversation to the understanding and maturity of the young person who is there. And I think it's not necessary for a bishop to be overly explicit or probing in those questions. He wants to understand how that individual feels about what they have done, so that he can help apply the right amount of repentance, if you will.
我认为这要取决于具体情况。给主教的一条建议是不要过于冒犯，要根据年轻人的理解能力和成熟度来调整谈话。主教没必要过于露骨或刻意盘问。他想了解个人对所作所为的感受，以便在必要时施加适当程度的悔改。
Eric says the church strongly believes that these bishop interviews with kids are a crucial part of its mission to help young people develop a close relationship with God by teaching them the standards for living a good and moral life. I pointed out to him that under the church's current guidelines, a bishop is still free to ask whatever explicit questions he wants. And inappropriate questions still seem to be happening.
埃里克说，教会坚信主教与孩子的这些面谈是其使命的关键部分，旨在通过传授道德生活准则，帮助年轻人与上帝建立亲密关系。我向他指出，根据教会当前的指南，主教仍然可以自由提出任何他想要的露骨问题。而不恰当的问题似乎仍在发生。
I mean, I guess what's the downside to making it super clear what they can and can't ask?
我是说，明确规定他们能问和不能问什么，有什么坏处吗？
Well, I think the conversation needs to be according to the understanding of that young person. You may have a young woman who is 11 years old, or 12 years old, 13 years old, who is completely innocent. You may have one of her counterparts who is of the same age, but very, very mature in her thinking, and the ways of the world, and so forth. And so the conversation would be very different for those two individuals. And that's what's outlined in the guidelines for bishops, as far as interviews.
嗯，我认为谈话需要符合年轻人的理解。你可能有一个完全天真的11岁、12岁或13岁女孩，也可能有一个同龄但思想非常成熟、见多识广的女孩。所以对于这两个人，谈话会非常不同。这就是主教面谈指南中概述的内容。
In other words, bishops need the flexibility to ask whatever they think is needed. He pointed out the church did revise its guidelines for bishop interviews this year to allow parents to be in the room and to share with the parents the basic topics that they'll cover beforehand.
换句话说，主教需要灵活性去问任何他们认为必要的问题。他指出教会确实在今年修订了面谈指南，允许家长在场，并事先与家长分享将涵盖的基本主题。
So why did you set new guidelines?
那么，你们为什么要设定新指南呢？
I think this is a church that is always growing, and learning, and looking to do better. And I think there was seen an opportunity to improve the interactions between young people and bishops. And so those guidelines were set.
我认为这是一个一直在成长、学习并寻求做得更好的教会。我认为人们看到了改善年轻人与主教之间互动的机会。所以设立了那些指南。
And is that because the way that questions were asked before were wrong?
是因为以前提问的方式是错的吗？
No, I don't think so. I think it's a learning process. I think the way that the church is taking accountability is by constantly seeking to improve.
不，我不这么认为。我认为这是一个学习过程。我认为教会负责任的方式是不断寻求改进。
You specifically said the word accountability. And I think that the church needs accountability in acknowledging that this process caused harm.
你特别提到了“负责任”这个词。我认为教会需要承认这个过程造成了伤害，这才是负责任。
I think that what the church is trying to do is to constantly improve, to look for ways in which this can be made better.
我认为教会正在做的是不断改进，寻找使之变得更好的途径。
Absolutely.
绝对。
That those interactions can improve.
使互动变得更好。
But I guess what I'm saying is in order to improve, there needs to be an admission. It feels a little like an argument I might get in with a boyfriend, or my husband, where I'm like-- so can you tell me that you did something wrong? And they're like, I'll do better. And you're like, no, but first you have to tell me you did something wrong. And then it's like, no, I'll do better. And it's like, will you just tell me, just so I know that you know that this was wrong?
但我说的是，为了改善，需要先承认。这感觉有点像我和男友或丈夫争吵，我会说：“你能告诉我你做错了吗？”他们说：“我会做得更好。”我说：“不，首先你得承认你做错了。”然后他们说：“不，我会做得更好。”就像：“你能不能告诉我，让我知道你明白这是错的？”
I've had those conversations with my wife, too.
我和妻子也有过那样的对话。
Uh-huh. And so do you understand what I'm asking?
嗯哼。那么你明白我在问什么吗？
I do. I do.
我明白，我明白。
And do you understand why it's important to me to hear that?
那你明白为什么听到这个对我来说很重要吗？
Yeah. And I think, as I said, were you to come into my office as your bishop or stake president, I would sit down and council with you, and make sure you understood-- and we would understand together, why did you feel that way? What were you feeling? And how can we make you feel better? But what I can't do is go back and change your experience, your perception, your feelings that you had at that time.
是的。如我所说，如果你作为我的教会成员走进我的办公室，我会坐下来建议你，确保你理解——我们一起理解，为什么你会有这种感觉？你当时感受到了什么？我们怎样才能让你感觉更好？但我无法回头改变你的经历、你的认知和你当时感受到的情绪。
Before I was baptized at the age of eight, I had to meet with the bishop. He said that I was going to be accountable for my sins from this moment on. He explained this using a dry erase board. You'll commit sins. He drew big black blobs across the white backdrop. But you can repent. He took an eraser and wiped the board until it was white again.
在8岁受洗前，我必须见主教。他说从这一刻起，我要为我的罪负责。他用一块白板解释了这个。你会犯罪。他在白色背景上画了几个大黑点。但你可以悔改。他拿过擦子把黑点擦掉，直到白板变得洁净如新。
This was a speech a lot of Mormon kids got. Back when I was in the church, I was hooked on the feeling I got when my bishops told me I was forgiven, and clean again. I could never sit with the discomfort I felt over my sexuality. And look, I no longer believe that these men speak for God or have any authority over me. But I can't shake the feeling of wanting to be clean, to have someone else who knows tell me I'm OK.
这是许多摩门教孩子听到的演讲。在教会时，我沉迷于主教告诉我“我被宽恕了、洁净了”的那种感觉。我永远无法面对因性欲而产生的局促感。听着，我不相信这些男人代表上帝或对我拥有任何权威。但我无法摆脱那种想变“干净”的感觉，想让一个知情者告诉我“我没问题”。
I probably should accept that there is no way that board is going to stay white. Why would I even want it to? What's so bad about drawing on it? Isn't that what it's for? But then, the second I think this, I hear another voice, "such is the way of an adulterous woman-- she eateth and wipeth her mouth and sayeth, I have done no wickedness." That's what my bishops taught me.
我大概应该接受那块板子不可能一直洁净的。为什么我还要指望它洁净？在那上面涂画有什么坏处吗？它不就是为此存在的吗？但紧接着，当我这样想时，我听到了另一个声音：“淫妇的道，也是这样，她吃了，擦了嘴，就说：我没有行恶。”这就是我的主教教给我的。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, something that might happen to you in the hospital that you would probably be unhappy about, and you would never know that it happened. Details in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
艾尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，在医院里可能会发生在你身上的一件事，你可能会很不高兴，却永远不会知道它发生了。细节在芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续播出后揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- "But That's What Happened," stories of women in situations where something unsettling happens. And sometimes, it is even hard to explain what felt wrong. And it takes a while to sort out the truth. We've arrived at Act 2 of our program, Act 2-- "While You Were Out." Lilly Sullivan has this story of something that happens to women without their consent. And they usually never find out that it happened. Here's Lilly.
这里是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“但这确实发生了”，讲述女性在面临令人不安的情况下的故事。有时，解释哪里不对劲甚至很困难。需要时间去理清事实。我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕——“当你不在时”。莉莉·沙利文讲述了这个女性在未经同意的情况下发生的事情。通常她们永远不知道。下面请听莉莉的报道。
About 10 years ago, Dan Wainberg was a medical student in Canada. It was his first year working in a hospital shadowing doctors. One day he goes to his first gynecological surgery. He had never been in a gynecological operating room before.
大约10年前，丹·温伯格是加拿大的医学生。那是他在医院跟随医生实习的第一年。有一天，他去参加了人生第一次妇科手术。他以前从没进过妇科手术室。
So I came into the room with the patient already under a general anesthetic, so sedated, not conscious.
我进入房间时，病人已经接受了全身麻醉，所以镇静了，没有意识。
That's routine. The patient is usually under by the time the surgeon arrives. So the lead surgeon did a pelvic exam on her, also routine, and then turned to Dan and said, now you try.
那是例行公事。病人通常在主刀医生到达时已经睡着了。所以主刀医生给她做了盆腔检查，这也是常规，然后转头对丹说：“现在你试试。”
And the gynecologist sent me over to the bed to do a pelvic exam on this woman.
于是妇科医生让我去床边，给这个女人做盆腔检查。
Dan had done a couple pelvic exams before, but never on somebody who was unconscious. To do a pelvic exam, a doctor inserts their fingers into a patient's vagina to examine the cervix and uterus. The doctor places another hand on the abdomen and presses down trying to catch the ovaries between the hand on the abdomen and the hand in the vagina to check for abnormalities. And while Dan was doing all this, the surgeon walked away.
丹以前做过几次盆腔检查，但从未在无意识的人身上做过。盆腔检查时，医生将手指伸入病人的阴道检查子宫颈和子宫。医生将另一只手放在腹部向下压，试图在腹部和阴道的手之间触探卵巢，以检查是否有异常。而当丹做这些时，主刀医生走开了。
And he went off to do something else. And so I was left there by myself doing a pelvic exam on an unconscious woman as someone who really didn't have a lot of knowledge of what I'm supposed to be feeling for. And I thought to myself, who would consent to something like this? And I know that my mind wandered to, if the woman knew what was going on, you know, that she'd probably be pretty upset, and justifiably so. You know, I just thought, what am I doing? And what would this woman think if she were to wake up right now?
他去干别的事了。所以我被留在那儿独自给一个无意识的女人做检查，而我作为一个人，对该感觉什么真没多少知识。我心想，谁会同意这种事？我知道我的思绪飘向了：如果这女人知道发生了什么，她肯定会很不高兴，而且完全有理由不高兴。我只是想，我在干什么？如果她现在醒来，会怎么想？
As soon as this thought hit him, he stopped, walked away.
这个念头一闪而过，他停下并走开了。
I don't think anyone paid any attention to me whatsoever, including the surgeon who was supposed to be basically my supervisor, or teacher. After that surgery, well, I felt so uncomfortable with the initial exam that I mustered up the courage to talk to the surgeon, my supervisor. And I asked him to please make sure, you know, from now on, just make sure they know I'm here. And ask for their consent for me to do an exam. I don't want to be-- yeah, I just felt like I didn't want that on my conscience. It didn't feel good.
我想没人注意我，包括那个本该是我的指导老师的主刀医生。那次手术后，我对最初的检查感到非常不安，于是鼓起勇气和主刀医生谈了谈。我请他以后一定要确保让病人知道我在场，并询问她们是否同意让我做检查。我不想……我只是觉得我不想让它压在我的良心上。感觉不好。
Oh, yeah. How did he react?
噢，是啊。他有什么反应？
I think he just kind of brushed it off and said OK. You know-- yeah, sure.
我想他只是轻描淡写地说了声“好吧”。你知道……是的，当然。
The night after that first surgery, Dan was still really upset. So he called his older sister, Sarah. She was in med school, too, a year ahead. And she was like, yeah, so?
那次手术后的晚上，丹依然非常心烦。于是他给姐姐萨拉打了电话。她也是医学生，高一年级。她说：“是的，那又怎样？”
I thought about all the times that I'd been asked to do the exact same thing. And when it happened to me, I didn't really think twice about it. I actually thought, oh, this is a fantastic learning opportunity. Because I found learning the pelvic exam a little awkward also.
我回想起自己所有被要求做同样事情的经历。当它发生在我身上时，我没想两次。我甚至觉得：噢，这是一个很棒的学习机会。因为我发现学习盆腔检查也稍微有点尴尬。
So when the surgeon invited me to also do a pelvic exam, I thought, great. I'd love to. And I don't think it had ever occurred to me even once that I might be doing something unethical. It just seemed like a normal part of practice.
所以当外科医生邀请我也做一次检查时，我觉得：太好了，我很乐意。我想我甚至从未想过我可能在做不道德的事。这看起来只是实习的一个正常部分。
It was kind of normal. Pelvic exams are hard to learn. Frankly, under the best of circumstances, they're uncomfortable, awkward. So for years in teaching hospitals, a common way to train students was that when someone was unconscious during a gynecological surgery, the head surgeon would do the exam and then a student would repeat the exam for practice.
这确实算正常。盆腔检查很难学。坦白说，在最好的情况下，它们也让人不适、尴尬。所以多年来在教学医院里，培训学生的一种常见方式是，当有人在妇科手术麻醉期间无意识时，主刀医生会做检查，然后学生会为了练习重复检查一次。
As far as consent goes, whenever anyone goes to a hospital, they sign an overall release form. At a teaching hospital, which lots of hospitals are, there's a part on the form that says something like, I acknowledge that medical students may be part of my treatment team. That's what a teaching hospital is, teaching people how to do stuff.
至于同意，任何人去医院都要签署一份综合发布表。在教学医院（很多医院都是），表上会有一栏写着类似：“我承认医学生可能是我的治疗团队成员。”这就是教学医院的本质，教人怎么做事。
These kinds of exams aren't just a thing in Canada. They're common in the US, too. Rectal exams happen the same way for men while they're unconscious during prostate surgery. And the more Sara thought about it, she started to feel weird, too.
这些检查不仅在加拿大，在美国也很常见。男性在前列腺手术中无意识时，直肠检查也是同样进行的。萨拉越想越觉得奇怪。
I think, actually, I probably felt a little bit embarrassed. So my first reaction was just to say, oh, what did you do? But in my head, I was thinking, oh, man. Why haven't I ever thought about this before?
我想其实我当时可能感到有点尴尬。所以第一反应只是问“你做了什么？”但在脑海里，我在想：天哪，我为什么从没想过这件事？
And then how did you feel about that reaction now? Do you have a different feeling about your initial--
那你现在对那个反应感觉如何？你对最初的……有不同的感觉吗？
Oh, yeah, no, I think it's horrifying, absolutely. I think, like, what's wrong with me? Why didn't this occur to me that I hadn't actually met this woman before? And it never occurred to me. And I think that's pretty horrible. Yeah, it's one of those dirty little secrets of medicine.
噢，当然，我觉得这太可怕了，绝对的。我想：“我怎么了？为什么我没意识到我根本没见过这个女人？”这件事从未闪过我的念头。我觉得这太可怕了。是的，这是医学界那些阴暗的小秘密之一。
After they hung up, Sara kept thinking about it, obsessing over the women, the patients getting these pelvic exams. Do they know that this might happen under anesthesia? And if not, how they feel about it? Sarah had to do a research project for school that year. And she wanted to look at this.
挂断后，萨拉一直想着这件事，痴迷于那些接受盆腔检查的女性患者。她们知道麻醉下可能会发生这种事吗？如果不知道，她们会怎么想？萨拉那年要为学校做一个研究课题，她想调查这个。
I specifically started talking to my boyfriend about it. Because he had wanted to be my research partner. And I said, oh, I've got this great idea. Let's do our research project on pelvic exams that are done without consent. And he said, no way. I do not want to be your research partner for that.
我特别开始和男友谈论这件事。因为他想做我的研究伙伴。我说：“噢，我有个好主意，我们来做关于‘未经同意的盆腔检查’的研究课题吧。”他说：“绝对不行，我才不要做这个的研究伙伴。”
Why?
为什么？
He felt that the pelvic exam under anesthesia is an incredibly important learning opportunity for male students. And he thought that even by looking at this issue, we were opening up a big can of worms. And he didn't want to have anything to do with it. He thought it was wrong that I was even looking into this issue.
他觉得麻醉下的盆腔检查对男学生来说是极其重要的学习机会。他认为即使审视这个问题，我们也在打开一个潘多拉魔盒。他不想和这件事有任何瓜葛。他觉得我调查这个问题本身就是错的。
Oh, wow.
哦，天哪。
Yeah.
是的。
So you guys had some--
所以你们……
We were not a match made in heaven.
我们不是天造地设的一对。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
He never came around on that one. Sara found that most of her classmates had done exams like this, practice exams on anesthetized women. And lots of them had never really thought about it either until Sara pointed it out to them.
他始终没转过弯来。萨拉发现她的大多数同学都做过这种检查，在麻醉的女性身上练习检查。许多人也从未真正思考过它，直到萨拉指出来。
Did you notice that women thought something different from men or was it all--
你有没有注意到女性和男性的想法不同，还是说……
Yes. Yes, I think a lot of men felt the same way my boyfriend did, that this is how we're going to learn. Because women don't always let us do this when they're awake. So we need to learn while they're asleep. For sure.
是的，是的。我觉得很多男性和我的男友感觉一样，认为这就是我们学习的方式。因为女性不总是在清醒时让我们做这个，所以我们需要在她们睡着时学习。确实如此。
The next year, she decided to survey a bunch of female patients at her teaching hospital and see what they said. Did they know that medical students might do exams? How did the women feel about it? Do patients want to be asked for consent beforehand? No one had ever studied that before.
第二年，她决定调查她所在的教学医院的一群女性病人，看看她们怎么说。她们知道可能有医学生参与检查吗？女性对此感觉如何？病人希望事先被询问是否同意吗？以前从没人研究过这一点。
At the time, I was like, come on, what's the big deal? Let's ask the question and find out what the answer is. I thought it's about time somebody really answers the question-- if you ask women, are they going to say yes? Right? Are they going to say yes or are they going to say no? That was the question that nobody had asked yet.
那时我想：“得了吧，这有什么大不了的？让我们问问，看答案是什么。”我觉得现在是有人真正回答这个问题的时候了——如果你问女性，她们会说愿意吗？对吧？她们会同意还是拒绝？这是以前没人问过的问题。
Here's what Sara and her research partners found. They polled 102 female surgery patients at their teaching hospital's pelvic floor disorder center. So that's women who are likely to have had pelvic surgery or who were likely to have it in the near future. The vast majority, 81% of them, had no idea that a med student might do a pelvic exam on them while they were asleep. And most said, yeah, they wanted to be asked.
这是萨拉和她的研究伙伴发现的。她们调查了盆腔修复中心102名女性手术病人。这些女性很可能做过或即将做盆腔手术。绝大多数（81%）不知道医学生可能会在她们睡着时做盆腔检查。大多数人表示：是的，她们希望被征求意见。
And here's the most surprising thing they found. 53% of women said they actually wouldn't mind being examined by a student while unconscious as long as someone asked them for permission beforehand. So a real find-- women would say yes. All you had to do was ask. So just ask, right? Problem solved.
最令人惊讶的是：53%的女性表示，只要事先征得允许，她们实际上不介意在无意识时由学生进行检查。所以，真正的结论是：女性会同意的。只要问一下就行了。只需询问，对吧？问题解决了。
After Sara and her co-authors published their research, people flipped out. The Globe and Mail wrote an article about it. People were shocked to learn that this was something that went on at all. Soon afterward, the medical guidelines in Canada changed. The Society of Obstetricians and Gynecologists, also the Association of Professors of Obstetrics and Gynecology revised their positions. They said that doctor should always ask for specific consent for this kind of exam.
在萨拉和她的合著者发表研究后，人们炸锅了。《环球邮报》写了一篇报道，人们对这种事情竟然会发生感到震惊。很快，加拿大的医疗准则变了。妇产科医师协会和妇产科教授协会修正了立场，称医生应始终就此类检查寻求明确同意。
In the US, the American Medical Association, the American College of Obstetricians and Gynecologists, and the Association of American Medical Colleges, they've also condemned this kind of pelvic exam. It's illegal in five states, Virginia, California, Hawaii, Illinois, and Oregon. A lot of teaching hospitals say they don't do it anymore, that it's a thing of the past.
在美国，美国医学会、妇产科医师学会和医学院协会也谴责了此类检查。它在五个州——弗吉尼亚、加利福尼亚、夏威夷、伊利诺伊和俄勒冈——是违法的。许多教学医院说他们不再这样做了，这已成过去式。
But medical students say it still happens. A couple of years ago, a biomedical ethicist named Phoebe Friesen had just started teaching medical ethics at Mount Sinai Medical School in New York. The students who were following doctors in hospitals had to talk about ethical dilemmas in medicine.
但医学生们说它依然在发生。几年前，生物伦理学家菲比·弗里森刚开始在纽约西奈山医学院教授医学伦理学。那些跟随医生实习的学生必须谈论医学中的伦理困境。
And when I was working with students who were in their OB-GYN clerkship, a lot of them brought up this practice and the fact that they'd been asked to perform pelvic exams on women under anesthetic who hadn't consented. And this one came up all the time, in nearly every session that I did. And generally, everyone was often sort of seeking permission or consensus that this is OK.
当我和正在实习妇产科的学生们交流时，他们很多人提到了这种做法，以及他们被要求在未征得同意的情况下给麻醉下的女性做盆腔检查的事实。几乎每次讨论都会出现这个问题。总的来说，大家都在寻求允许或共识，觉得这是可以的。
Wow, so all the students had experienced this?
哇，所以所有学生都经历过？
Yeah, so I think as long as they were participating in gynecological surgeries, it was really the norm. But I think a lot of them felt kind of confused or maybe ashamed. I think a lot of them were seeking reassurance that that was OK. And I just ended up talking to so many who felt uncomfortable.
是的，只要他们参与妇科手术，这真的就是常态。但我认为他们很多人感到困惑，甚至羞耻。他们很多人在寻求某种“那是没关系的”安慰。而我最终和太多感到不舒服的学生交谈过。
They were doing these pelvic exams at a bunch of different hospitals around New York City. Phoebe had never heard anything about these kinds of exams. She was horrified. She started asking everyone, random students she'd meet at conferences, parties.
他们在纽约市的很多医院做这些盆腔检查。菲比以前从未听说过这些检查，她感到震惊。她开始询问所有人，她在会议上、派对上见到的随机学生。
And she found that students had experienced it everywhere, at hospitals all over the country. Because teaching hospitals take a lot of patients without insurance or who are on Medicaid, these practice exams end up being done disproportionately on poor women, women of color, homeless women. Phoebe was surprised to learn there are a lot of people who are still in favor of it.
她发现学生们到处都经历过，在全国各地的医院里。因为教学医院接收很多没有保险或领取医疗补助的病人，这些练习检查最终不成比例地针对贫困女性、少数族裔女性、无家可归的女性。菲比很惊讶地发现仍有很多人支持它。
And I think especially there was a lot of men who were dismissive, and there was a lot of people from within the medical community. Or a lot of people would say things like, well, what you don't know can't hurt you.
而且我觉得尤其是很多男性对此不屑一顾，医学界内部也有很多人持这种态度。很多人会说：“你不知道就不会受伤。”
Oh my god.
天哪。
That kind of response, which I felt like was really, really weird.
那种回应，我觉得真的很奇怪。
So she decided to dissect the ethics of it and put together an article for the Journal of Bioethics. It's one of the leading journals in the field. She parsed out five common arguments in support of examining unconscious patients, evaluated each of them, and concluded that the practice is unethical. The response from doctors? Not so good.
于是她决定剖析其中的伦理，为《生物伦理学杂志》撰写了一篇文章，那是该领域领先的杂志之一。她解析了五个支持检查无意识病人的常见论点，一一评估，并断定该做法是不道德的。医生的反应？并不怎么好。
Some said these exams are necessary for teaching. Some said these exams never happen, which, of course, can't both be true. One argument Phoebe has heard a lot, the vagina is just a body part. . Be a professional. Don't be a prude. She calls this the "is the vagina different from the mouth" objection. Sara heard this one a lot when she was doing her research. Here's Sara.
有人说这些检查对教学是必要的，有人说这些检查根本不会发生——当然两者不可能同时为真。菲比听到过很多的一种论点是：“阴道只是个身体部位……专业点。别当个道貌岸然的人。”她称之为“阴道与嘴有何不同”的反驳。萨拉做研究时也经常听到。请听萨拉的说法。
So who cares? This is just another exam. This is just another thing that medical students do in the hospital. Why is it different than looking in someone's mouth, or looking at their hip? How is this different?
所以谁在乎呢？这只是另一个检查而已。这只是医学生在医院做的另一件事。它和看别人的嘴或臀部有什么不同？它有什么区别？
How is it different?
有什么区别？
The thing that really makes it different is not what we, as doctors, think about it. The thing that makes it different is what the patients think about it. And if you ask women, they think it's different. So it's different, yeah.
真正让它不同的不是我们作为医生怎么看。真正让它不同的，是病人们怎么看。如果你问女性，她们认为不同。所以，它就是不同。
For me, I would want to know if somebody was going to be examining my vagina while I was asleep. Absolutely, I would like to know. I mean, I've been in that situation. I've been there. I've been that crying woman waiting to go into surgery. So I understand what it feels like.
对我来说，如果有人要在我不省人事时检查我的阴道，我会想知道的。绝对会。我经历过那种情况。我去过那里。我当过那个等着进手术室哭泣的女人。所以我理解那种感觉。
Sara has had gynecological surgery under anesthesia. After a miscarriage.
萨拉在流产后，曾有过麻醉下做妇科手术的经历。
I've been in an operating room, asleep. You're asleep in a cold operating room with your feet up in the air, and a bunch of strangers around you. And you're exposed for all these people to see. It's very emotional. Yeah, it is. Yeah, because you're very vulnerable when you're asleep. I mean, before I delivered a baby, they asked me if I wanted a med student or a resident in the room. So I think if I'm asleep, I should be offered the same courtesy.
我在手术室睡着过。你睡在一个冰冷的手术室里，双脚吊在半空，周围是一群陌生人。你处于暴露状态，所有人都看着你。这非常感性。是的，确实。因为你在睡着时非常脆弱。我是说，生孩子前，他们问我是否想要医学生或住院医在场。所以我想如果我睡着了，我也应该得到同样的礼遇。
For this story, I wanted to talk to women who have been examined under anesthesia without their consent. But I couldn't find anyone. These exams don't become part of a woman's medical records. They don't go into their charts at the hospital. And of course, this happens while they're unconscious. So pretty much, by definition, anyone who's gone through this will probably never know.
为了这个故事，我想采访那些在未经同意下接受麻醉检查的女性，但我找不到人。这些检查不会记录在病人的医疗记录里，不会进入医院的图表。当然，这发生在她们无意识时。所以基本上，经历过这些的人可能永远都不会知道。
Lilly Sullivan.
莉莉·沙利文。
[MUSIC -- "SISTERS UNARMED" BY 79.5]
（音乐——79.5乐团《姐妹们缴械》）
(SINGING) Why should I change 'cause the world is evil? Why rearrange the way that I am?
（唱）为什么要改变，只因世界邪恶？为什么要重组那个本真的我？
Our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. The people who put together today's show includes Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Jarrett Floyd, Stephanie Foo, Damien Grave, Michelle Harris, David Kestenbaum, Anna Martin, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们今天的节目由莉莉·沙利文制作。参与今天节目的团队包括艾尔娜·贝克、本·卡尔霍恩、达纳·切维斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、贾雷特·弗洛伊德、斯蒂芬妮·傅、达米安·格雷夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、大卫·克里斯滕鲍姆、安娜·马丁、米基·米克、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、克里斯托弗·斯维塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和戴安·吴。
Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton. Special thanks today to Greg Prince, Matt Bowman, Taylor Petrey, Peggy Fletcher Stack, Louise Seamster, Alexandra Duncan, and Sue Ross. Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 650 episodes for absolutely free.
我们的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德。执行编辑是苏珊·伯顿。特别感谢今天的格雷格·普林斯、马特·鲍曼、泰勒·彼得里、佩吉·弗莱彻·斯塔克、路易丝·西姆斯特、亚历山德拉·邓肯和苏·罗斯。我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，您可以免费收听我们超过650集的节目档案。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he and I ended up at this fancy party at the Kardashians' last week. Some of his cocktail banter, I don't know, it was so awkward.
《此美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX负责分发。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，上周我和他在卡戴珊家的聚会上碰到了。他的一些鸡尾酒会闲聊，我不知道，太尴尬了。
Is there anything in your life, Kim, that hasn't been resolved with the proper priesthood authority?
金，你的生活中有什么是没经过适当的圣职权柄解决的吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周为您带来更多《此美国生活》的故事。